hahaha
your first look at the Big Bad Romance
is here yes after Turning Heads as
Patricia reggiani and 2021's House of
Gucci Lady Gaga is transforming yet
again in the upcoming Joker sequel I
subscribe to
unconventional punishments green doesn't
go with my lipstick
on Tuesday director Todd Phillips
released a first look photo of Lady Gaga
and Joaquin Phoenix from 2024's Joker
Fally at duh back in August Gaga
announced that she would be joining the
Joker film and fans are more than happy
that the Grammy winner will be playing
the iconic Harley Quinn a role made
famous by Margot Robbie what was that I
should kill everyone and Escape
sorry
it's the voices Phoenix is obviously
returning as the Joker a role that won
him the Oscar for best actor in 2020.
are you having any negative thoughts
all I have are negative thoughts are you
excited for Lady Gaga's performance in
Joker faliada share your thoughts in the
comments below